i've i've experienced a lot of the
similar similar things right when when
you had that video
of the woman saying the audience
wouldn't care about that you know why
should we report on bitcoin the audience
is not going to care about that i'm like
oh i know exactly what they're saying
and then when i thought it was
interesting too because there's two
sides to this
you mentioned that they're just
interested in the executive's opinion
and that's also bad we don't want
newsrooms
where you have one executive saying i
just want propaganda for my world view
and we also don't want a newsroom that
says just feed the the peasants whatever
confirmation bias you can give them
you want an eclectic group of real
reporters
with varying world views seeking out the
truth seeking out information
and disseminating it and that means
often you'll have something that will be
offensive to republicans offensive to
democrats young people hate it old
people will hate it
and then there will be a lot of things
that people appreciate a big expose in a
corporate malfeasance but when you have
when you have a ceo you know what
happens when you have an executive
sticking his finger in the editorial
i've seen it they say oh is that what's
that story there's a large soda company
that's doing something wrong
well they sponsor us so we're not gonna
report on that and then they they stick
their finger into the news reporting and
they shut down very important stories
about corporate malfeasance
in the inverse you have people saying
just tell the audience whatever they
want to hear and you can't have either
that it's got to be about
seeking truth and providing information
whether people like it or not exactly in
fact there's another
big story that i that i have been trying
to get out to viewers there's a few
things that i need to do to
to verify what's going on and get it out
there and and i presented this story to
my bosses
and a couple months ago i'm not going to
go into detail because i'm still working
on this story but
uh i told my bosses there's two people i
need to track down on the ground
i need to just run into them and have a
mic and hey
so what's going on you know and they
said
absolutely not they were just like oh
what you're crazy
we would never just confront someone
like that it was like what
like that that is journalism yeah
getting
getting that person this is this is a
potentially very dark story if this if
what happened is true
that is dirty yeah luke's luke's got
experience with running up to people and
i mean that's what it's real journalism
going up to people doorstepping them
asking them a question that's not
scripted everything we see on the
mainstream media right now is
carefully written carefully scripted joe
biden gets pre-approved questions in
front of him
that he has cue cards for that he
answers there is no i can tell you the
only reason i can verify that yeah yeah
and then i remember being
at a lecture for condoleezza rice and
she was she was doing a q a
allegedly from the general public and
she was asked questions
and then i remembered later that day
watching the jon stewart show because
this was a few years ago
the same exact questions that allegedly
came from the audience
was what jon stewart was asking
condoleezza rice in this
you know pre-scripted interview that she
knew all the right talking points to
sell her book
she probably sent him the questions and
said this is how i realized
and this is this is their book this is
this is all a big illusion and i
remember being there
right before you went from vice to to to
fusion and disney i remember i was like
timmy no
don't join the dark side don't do it no
wasn't vice bad enough i was like i
already had enough conflicts with vice
there was
some drama between me and them we even
shot a full skit about us testing less
lethal weapons on each other
we sat down got tear gassed together oh
we did a whole segment
and then and then we couldn't even no
one even saw that video footage well
that's different that's
that that was more like a major
corporation
that wanted to be cool exactly and
didn't understand
anything i told them and what we did was
really freaking i was like we want to go
to a secure location where we can
we can test out these police tactics in
an open field
they brought us to a parking lot at
mcdonald's and i'm like we we
can't we can't do this here like this
you can't release tear gas in a parking
lot like what are you doing yeah the
feds showed up it's a long crazy story
uh exciting yeah uh it was wild but um
what you experienced happening to you
the kind of golden handcuffs
happened to a lot of people whether it's
philip donohue whether it's jesse van
cura
there's a lot of people reporting how
they get bought out by big companies and
all they have to do is not do anything
guys yet when you said golden handcuffs
i was like
what a concept that i i almost felt in
some ways like that's
been something that's been happening to
me the more i push back internally
i i mean i started i started
aggressively pushing back
against my bosses on these things like i
lost all fear of confrontation with my
bosses when i saw the depths to which
they stooped late last summer i was like
okay
i don't want to be a part of this
company anyway so i'm not going to
tiptoe around my bosses
and i started to i started to call them
out every chance i got
every time they did something sketchy i
would call them out and what started to
happen
is i i started to like get
any day off that i wanted i got like two
weeks off over christmas and and new
year's
and i i i never have to work weekends
uh it's just so i i don't i don't want
to ask you
to answer this about you personally but
um
would you say that these local newsrooms
in general on average
pay well uh in
in houston it's uh it's a decent amount
i i mean it's not like relatives but
it's not it's not low it's it's probably
more than most people make
right that's what i'm wondering you know
for like somebody who lives in the
houston area maybe they're a a trades
they work a trade of some sort or maybe
they have you know they drive uber
or they maybe work at a walmart or
something yeah we're definitely making
more than those people
yeah this is what i find really
fascinating about the whole thing is
it's almost
like the whole system relies on you just
recognizing
that you are a privileged elite and you
don't want to leave the club
right i walk into vice when i first
started there a lot of those people got
paid really poorly let's be honest like
vice didn't pay out
while they were notorious for it but
there are many news outlets
uh um in new york i shouldn't even call
them news outlets
they pay an insane amount of money 60
grand to write listicles about you know
like different hamsters they saw on the
internet
it's like why are they getting paid so
much per year when the guy who cleans
the toilets
gets paid a third of that or or or half
that why is it that the guy has to wait
around in the sewer is getting paid less
than the person
who's fresh out of college with no
experience writing trash
for the internet i think it's because
control of information is extremely
important so they want people to look
around and say
i don't want to be a garbage man they
they do like i mean this is what we hear
when we grow up right
they they say oh if you don't go to
school you could end up being a garbage
man
my dad never told me that he said
garbage man might be very happy he
probably makes great money better than
the guy at mcdonald's
mcdonald's guy's probably happy too who
knows some people probably aren't happy
happiness has nothing to do with that
so i found that you know interesting but
i think about how we teach our kids this
you don't want to be a burger flipper
you don't want to be a garbage man then
all of a sudden these people
they get this privileged access where
they're getting paid a bunch of money to
do basically nothing it's not real work
i'm talking about new york blogs i'm not
talking about actual journalism
they don't want to leave that club they
don't want to step out of line there's
money to be made
so golden handcuffs works in a couple
different ways when you get a contract
they tell you hey we're not going to use
this story every single time you you get
one no we're not interested no we're not
interested have a nice day
then they just basically you end up
sitting in the corner of an office
getting paid decently
doing nothing yep the other kind of
golden handcuffs is more of the peer
pressure kind where it's like well
you're not a bigot are you
you agree with us that is what is
prolific in tv news
they they the wokeness the the the oh
you're not
you're not it's basically you're you're
not right wing at all are you
right that was a slightly right leaning
pitch there you pitched a story that uh
well you know what are your views you
know and everyone in
in news is terrified to ever be thought
to
possibly lean to the right you have to
be leaning to the left which is
which is so sad you shouldn't be leaning
anywhere you should be just
looking for the facts period yeah uh but
in in
in looking for what the audience has
questions about
we as journalists have more access to
the audience than ever before
we get to just look at our own social
media comments and see what the audience
cares about and what they want answer
answers to and what i saw at fox is an
audience
screaming in the comment section
so frustrated the fox 26 viewers were so
disgusted with boxmas and their
questions were what i
started pitching in the meetings in our
morning editorial meetings
and and i watched the pitches get shot
down shot down shut down but isn't it
weird then when you had that supervisor
say
that you know the 5 p.m slot doesn't
make sense to talk about bitcoin because
the people who watched aren't interested
in it if the if
it's weird that they're they're kind of
doing both things like oh we know our
audience
won't like the story we won't do it
meanwhile you actually have people on
your social media saying hey we'd like
to know more about this
oh we're not going to do that either
right seems more like it was an excuse
for them to pick and choose what stories
they want to promote
of course they didn't want to promote
bitcoin bitcoin gives regular people a
way
out so i'll i'll put it this way i'm not
a financial advisor
do not take this to be financial advice
and i'm going to tell you about my
opinions
if you put money in a savings account
when i put money
in a savings account inflation devalues
my currency
the my ability to buy things diminishes
over time because the way the federal
reserve prints money
when i put my money in bitcoin the value
of the bitcoin
went up and the va my purchasing power
actually increased
teaching poor people that they could
find a way out
i have to imagine a lot of elites and
and rich people don't like the idea that
poor people can escape the system
they've created
yeah it's it's incredible you know i
just discovered bitcoin in november and
made some nice money nice money from it
november
yeah that was a good time yeah so it was
at around 13
000 or so and then uh and now it's at
40. and all the naysayers and all these
outlets keep wanting to keep wanting to
say oh no it was at 65 and now it fell
so it's bad and i'm just like yeah
look man if someone gave me a dollar
right now would i put it in a savings
account or would i put it in i put in
bitcoin
because because me personally my
personal opinion not financial advice
is that that dollar is going to retain
its value or increase i put in the
savings account it's going to it's going
to inflate and become worthless
but tim poor people getting rich is a
big no no we can't allow that we can
allow people to have their own
individual economic freedom and
sovereignty through crypto currencies
it's not about getting rich it's about
if i work
the value of my labor is retained
exactly and i totally agree with you and
that's why we have seen such concerted
efforts throughout the years i've been
hearing them ever since bitcoin went
from
400 to 200 ever since it went from 2000
to 800
it's always bitcoin is over it's
collapsing it's never going to become a
thing
it's horrible for the world it's it's
causing pollution
meanwhile look at the carbon created by
the military industrial complex look at
the carbon created by gold mining
and it's way higher than bitcoin i i
previously just put out a chart on my
twitter account
showing the exact amount of co2 caused
by all these other alternatives and
bitcoin is all the way down there very
low but
yet again elizabeth warren is the one
campaigning a huge war against bitcoin
trying to of course
control it regulate it and of course
make sure that people can't
enrich themselves some way or keep their
money
some way through the larger financial
crimes that are happening against the
public
right now thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time